[Music]
oh hey sam what's up hey
climb this whole mountain just tell you
guys about stock footage boom so in this
video we're going to tell you guys what
stock footage is how to create a world
with it stock elements for effects after
effects templates we're also going to
talk about how to sell your own stock
footage if you're making it but if you
need it like most of us do we're going
to be giving away a ton of free stock
footage elements at the end of this
video
with the help of our friends from
pond5's stock footage mega database so
let's say you're filming a low of the
rings parody
in iowa where it's all just planes and
you don't have a camera
and you're wondering how do i establish
this epic scenery but that's where
something like stock footage comes into
play also pretty much every tv show
where they're like here we are in
washington dc
basically that's just stock footage of
like the white house and it cuts to some
studio here in los angeles yeah nobody
shoes in washington dc no one shoots in
chicago anyways you guys are probably
wondering how can i use the stock
footage what should i be looking for and
you guys are also probably wondering
what about stock footage for effects so
first off we're gonna break it down
we're gonna talk about stock footage for
like telling a story we use like scenery
or something like that how to go about
using that as best as possible for
instance in our assassin's creed 4 video
we actually show a giant establishing
shot of the vessel sailing through the
water and what that does is it just
gives people a sense of perspective as
to where all this stuff is happening
we're seeing one boat on the ocean and
then when we cut the inside the boat
it's a totally different ship so it
really doesn't matter what it looks like
from the inside and the outside in the
if that's a different size or whatever
we could have easily replaced that
opening shot with pretty much any boat
any piece of footage we wanted and it
would have worked fine we actually went
through and did a bunch of research
seeing what was already out there to see
if there's already a cooler shot of a
pirate ship like sailing along because
if it's out there why not the stock
footage takes place those big wide
establishing shots where somebody else
has already gone to some special
location and done that shot for you so
it can be really useful in a really cool
way and easy way to make your films look
really big and epic the most common type
of stock footage that we use and most
likely you guys use is stock footage for
effects i'm talking muzzle flashes
bullet hits smoke fire obviously you
want a high resolution image you want to
make sure it's at a good frame rate
either 24 for your stuff you don't want
to get pal footage or 30 frames per
second stuff
you also want to make sure that uh the
footage is exposed properly for the shot
you're going to be doing this comes into
play mostly when doing fire and muzzle
flashes fire during the daytime versus
fire at night and how you're exposing
looks totally different at night it's
really bright really yellow really
orange in the daytime it's very faint
actually compared to everything else
obviously you don't want your stock
footage to be clipping the edges of
frame because that makes it pretty much
unusable when you see the little box of
form on screen one thing that most
people typically miss though is
whether their stock footage elements
come with alpha channels or not and this
has a big effect when you're trying to
composite it typically with fire or
things like that you can use a composite
mode like screen to just put it on your
footage and make it look natural but a
couple other things like dust and uh
blood and things like that those require
like an alpha channel because they're
solid it's not like some sort of color
effect that you're trying to overlay
onto your image however if you find that
one piece of footage that works
perfectly looks great it's everything
you need but it doesn't have alpha
channels it's okay because you can
actually generate alpha channels by
yourself and now after effects and if
you don't know how to do that our bullet
hits tutorial from two years back that
describes exactly how to generate alpha
channels for footage that doesn't have
any another thing you'll notice on some
effects footage is that some comes on a
black background which is good and some
comes on a green or blue background
which is bad it's actually kind of a
misguided attempt to generate alpha
channels on that stock footage when
you're dealing with lots of little
particles liquid stuff like that you
don't want that because you have motion
blur it comes into the edges and stuff
like that get the stuff on the black
backgrounds it'll look better later
trust me let's talk about after effects
templates what are these what are these
magical things called after effects
templates some people online have gone
forth and built amazing after effects
project files where literally all you
have to do is open it up and you select
the box and you can type in any text you
want you'll have a magnificent logo
already animated with a bunch of cool
effects they're very very useful to save
you a bunch of time for example if
you've seen the video googly eyes we use
an after effects template for the news
opening it's also really useful for
learning how other people have actually
done these things so for example if you
see an after effects template that has a
really cool element you can actually
download that template and take a look
at how it's all built it's all right
there it's just an after effects file
those things can be really useful and
they can save you a bunch of time
but did you guys also know that you can
sell your footage to make some money
yourself think about what people need
and don't have and what you have access
to that you can share let's save a bunch
of guns film your guns shooting because
a lot of people don't have guns and they
can't get their cool muzzle flashes
let's say you live in a buddhist temple
make stock footage of that because most
people don't have access to a freaking
buddhist temple it's an easy way to make
some money on the side with your film
skills all right guys we've been talking
about stock footage a whole bunch here
but you guys don't have any stock
footage you have to do any of this stuff
with guess what we have a bunch of free
stock footage lined up for you guys to
use we got mountains we got fire we got
muzzle flashes we met some guys from
pond5 which is a stock footage website
we told them about this idea so we
picked out 50 clips
of a bunch of cool stuff that you guys
can use for free it's sweet uh go check
it out at
pond5.com sam and nico also
if you guys want to sell your stuff like
we were talking about
they actually have one of the best deals
around for creators in terms of a
revenue split we're going to be
downloading some of it too and using it
in our videos so you should too you guys
back wait a minute they already used
that shot of the mountain i can't use
that shot of mountain no but they have
like bolt hits and smoke and stuff so
like we need we use like the same one
for every video over and over again it's
just like smoker 16 except we have a
smoker 17 now that we just keep using
there's probably a link in the
description if there's not one you can
already click on somewhere pond5.com sam
nico see you guys next week in another
video talking about cool stuff yep we
gotta go work on tether see ya oh yeah
[Music]